[Music]
the greatest thing about working on a
spider-man game is that you're working
on a spider-man game the hardest thing
is that it's a spider-man game we really
care about storytelling here at
insomniac and I think that's how we go
into every day we come here there's this
push to really get it right one of the
most compelling things about spider-man
is just when Peter Parker and
spider-man's worlds collide and we've
tried really hard to weave the two
stories together to create a story that
is not necessarily just a superhero
story but a human story as well so this
spider-man is a little different he's
older he's 23 so he's been spider-man
for eight years and kind of like an
athlete in the prime of his career he
started get good at this spider-man
thing nice thing about playing an
experienced fireman is that he's already
familiar with his powers right he's not
just discovering them we always think of
spider-man as we call him the acrobatic
improviser he's looking for not only how
he can take advantage of way the enemies
are positioned but what around him could
he use this object to grab with his webs
and throw an enemy we want people to not
only see the enemies in front of them
but the environment around to take
advantage of both of them he also knows
that the criminals out in the city know
how he works as well so he's got to mix
it up so even though he is more
experienced the challenges gonna be
bigger than he's ever faced before
spider-man has a rich history of having
great stories the core of our story is
this duality between being Peter Parker
and being spider-man
what's cool about mr. negative is that
he also has a duality he's got his
positive side as Martin Lee who runs two
homeless shelters in the city but he
also has his negative side when Peter
makes the connection that the leader of
the inner demons is the guy who my aunt
works for we got the perfect collision
of those two worlds
so many people have their own vision of
what spiderman should look like what he
should sound like and in the end we just
have to put a new and fresh twist on who
he is and for us it's really really
important to deliver those big spectacle
moments those near impossible scenarios
that only solar experiment can survive
and put you in that action you got this
you got this
we understand what this character makes
the people in here and we're making this
game with a lot of heart and we're gonna
do whatever it takes to give people the
ultimate spider-man experience the game
that they've been waiting for